Josiane merci d'être là bonjour vous
avez 73 ans bonsoir madame 1200 euros de
pension par mois oui deux petits enfants
à charge oui vous êtes obligé de
continuer à travailler à 73 ans vous
faites quoi je distribue des prospectus
pour une société que tout le monde
connaît et c'est un travail très
difficile parce que c'est très physique
200 en comptant le travail que vous
faites en plus
1200 de pensions d'accord et j'ai
travaillé 42 ans
et comme j'ai travaillé dans les banques
vous savez très bien qu'on ne compte pas
les doubles mois alors on nous prend au
SMIC au départ bien évidemment quand on
commence on nous prend au SMIC mais on
nous paye sur 15 mois alors quand je
suis tombé à la retraite les 25 années
bien évidemment c'était pour les
dernières
et donc à partir de ce moment-là
ça a baissé terriblement or ce qui se
passe c'est le mai 1200 euros monsieur
ils n'ont pas augmenté depuis 10 ans
alors moi je me retrouve avec une
retraite pareil que quelqu'un qui a
jamais bossé quoi parce que moi j'ai des
gens autour de moi dans mon village ils
ont jamais travaillé ils ont 900 € par
mois c'est ça au minimum
ils font ce qu'ils veulent c'est pas mon
problème mais j'estime que moi j'ai eu
des enfants j'ai travaillé en même temps
et mes enfants sont tous contribuables
je veux dire alors comment se fait-il
qu'il y ait des gens qui n'aient jamais
bossé qui n'ont pas d'enfants qui n'ont
jamais fait pour devenir des
contribuables et qui gagnent une
retraite alors ça faut me poser la
question maintenant il y a aussi une
autre question que je vais vous poser je
pense que Cyril m'en donne
l'autorisation les figurez-vous que je
paye quand même les cotisations retraite
la CG sur mon petit boulot qui vient en
complément moi j'en ai besoin pour payer
les activités côté sportive de mes
petits-enfants parce que malgré le Pass
de 50 euros pour jouer au rugby pour un
gosse c'est 200 euros dans mon village
j'habite un petit village profond de la
France où il y a rien il y a pas on est
obligé de prendre la voiture pour
n'importe quoi donc moi si vous voulez
c'est très dur pour nous je ne peux pas
acheter de poisson je ne peux pas
acheter tout le temps de la viande de
temps en temps j'emmène des petits au
McDo manger le Happy me la 4,95 et c'est
tout la sortie vous comprenez et j'ai
travaillé toute ma vie voilà alors moi
il y a quand même quelque chose que je
vais vous poser je pense que tout le
monde serait d'accord avec Cyril aussi
comment se fait-il que les sénateurs les
députés et tous ces gens là ils aient
des retraites spéciales il parle alors
plusieurs questions je veux répondre
on va peut-être commencer on va
peut-être commencer par le dernier point
si vous voulez alors la retraite
spéciale en fait c'est pas une retraite
spéciale des parlementaires c'est ce
qu'on appelle un régime autonome qui
nous fait une belle jambe parce que vous
allez dire c'est pareil bon en fait
l'Assemblée nationale est députée à
chaque fois qu'il y a une réforme des
retraites il s'applique il se l'applique
seulement la Constitution fait que parce
qu'il doit y avoir une autonomie des
parlementaires par rapport au
gouvernement c'est la séparation des
pouvoirs on ne peut pas dans un texte de
loi classique comme la loi des retraites
décidé pour les députés de changer la
retraite d'accord il faudrait ce qu'on
appelle une loi organique et une loi
différente qui est compliquée à faire
adopter en revanche ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que les députés ont déjà acté
et décider qu'il s'appliquerait les
mêmes modalités de la réforme des
retraites que celles qui vont être
amenées à voter dans quelques jours donc
soyez rassurés de ce point de vue là les
députés ils ont fait le choix et la
majorité essentielle a fait ce choix de
s'appliquer à elle-même ce qu'elle
demande aux Français premier point les
sénateurs ça peut être différent ils ne
se sont pas encore prononcés on n'y a
pas la majorité je peux pas parler à
leur place mais je veux bien le relayer
la question parce que je suis assez
d'accord avec vous pour dire que les
parlementaires ils doivent être logés à
la même enseigne le reste des Français
et ça c'est le premier point premier
point exemplarité
alors ensuite vous m'avez parlé de la
retraite de ceux qui sont à 960 euros
c'est à dire qu'ils ont la SPA le
minimum vieillesse Josiane je voudrais
vous parler de quelques personnes que
j'ai eu à rencontrer comme ministre des
Solidarités et puis quand j'étais à
Orchies dans le Pas-de-Calais il y a
deux semaines à la rencontre d'une
vingtaine de retraités qui ont des
petites pensions un peu comme vous
il y en avait il y avait là-bas trois ou
deux ou trois femmes c'était des femmes
qui touchaient le minimum enfin le
minimum de 960 euros alors il faut
savoir d'abord que si elles ont du
patrimoine au-dessus au dessus de 40000
euros l'état récupère au moment de la
succession ce qu'il a donné pour
permettre à quelqu'un de vivre à peu
près au niveau du seuil de pauvreté
d'accord avec la réforme des retraites
on va passer cette récupération de 40
000 à 100.000 euros c'est à dire toutes
les personnes qui ont moins de 100000
euros de patrimoine on va effectivement
leur donner leur compléter leurs revenus
jusqu'à hauteur de 960 euros parce que
on considère qu'une personne âgée en
dessous de 960 euros on vit pas on ne
vit pas et on assume
Josiane les personnes que j'ai vu qui
touchaient ces 960 euros les trois que
j'ai vu c'était ça va peut-être vous
parler ça va peut-être parler aux
artisans qui sont là au commerçants des
conjoints de collaboratrices vous savez
ce que c'est oh oui bah c'était les
secrétaires de leur mari commerçant
médecin ou autre et comment en fait
bosser toute leur vie mais qui était pas
déclaré et donc au moment de la retraite
on leur a dit madame vous n'avez pas
cotisé vous n'étiez pas déclaré donc il
y a pas de retraite mais moi j'en ai vu
moi ça me fend le cœur à chaque fois je
veux dire un truc ça me folker on peut
pas les retrouver on pourrait on peut
pas faire une mesure moi j'étais posé la
question de dire est-ce qu'on peut pas
les rattraper dans la loi mais par
définition comme elles sont pas connues
du fisc et ben on peut pas démontrer que
c'est bien cette situation là mais c'est
pour vous donner un exemple de personne
ensuite vous avez beaucoup
d'agriculteurs tous les minimum
vieillesse et qui n'ont pas cotisé
suffisamment non pas en termes d'années
ou de dureté du labeur mais parce que
leurs revenus étaient insuffisant pour
leur permettre d'avoir une retraite
supérieure à 1000 euros et donc moi
j'assume parfaitement ce mécanisme de
solidarité et même on l'a passé il était
à 800 et quelques euros on l'a passé à
900 puis là il est monté à 960 euros
parce que
je suis aussi l'augmentation du coût de
la vie ensuite Josiane pour ce qui vous
concerne il y a des éléments que vous
devriez regarder de près dans la réforme
des retraites parce que vous êtes en
situation de cumul emploi retraite c'est
la deuxième question la deuxième
remarque que vous avez fait et vous avez
raison vous dites alors que je touche ma
retraite avec ma retraite elle bouge pas
j'ai pris un boulot mais je cotise pour
la retraite sur le boulot ben ça le
cumul emploi retraite on le facilite on
le simplifie on le rend plus juste avec
la loi c'est à dire que les retraités
qui conserveront une activité à côté et
bien on va simplifier et supprimer des
cotisations qui aujourd'hui leur diminue
le petit pécule qui se font à côté ça va
être ça va dépendre du niveau de revenus
je vais pas vous dire de bêtises
là-dessus parce que le texte de loi est
en cours d'examen Parlement mais grosso
modo sachez que l'état d'esprit c'est de
ne plus vous forcer à cotiser pour un
truc que vous ne toucherez pas donc vous
voyez ça va plutôt dans le bon sens et
un autre élément sur la réforme des
retraites parce que je j'insiste et je
comprends et on va peut-être en discuter
et peut-être des gens qui vont me dire
qu'ils sont pas du tout d'accord etc
aucun problème j'assume qu'on puisse en
discuter juste un point sur lequel
j'insiste c'est que pour les gens qui
sont déjà retraités il y a que des
gagnants
avec la réforme parce que moi quand
j'étais député et sous la gauche et dans
le mandat précédent on a été amenés ça
vous parlera à sous indexer les pensions
de retraite c'est-à-dire qu'on les
augmenter moins que l'inflation voir à
geler les pensions de retraite pour
essayer de trouver l'équilibre financier
du système bah là comme on arrive à
équilibrer le système en demandant aux
gens de travailler un peu plus longtemps
par cette mécanisme de solidarité on
sait qu'on aura plus besoin de geler ou
de sous-indexer les pensions donc vos
pensions je tiens elles vont augmenter
et après vous avez la dernière situation
qui sont des retraités qui gagnent un
peu moins que vous mais qu'on
travaillait une carrière complète
c'est-à-dire qu'on bossait les
quarantaines qui ont et qui ont avaient
un salaire à peu près au niveau SMIC et
qui se retrouve avec 1050 ou 1100 euros
par mois eux on va les monter à 1200
euros par mois c'est à dire qu'on va se
qu'on appelle la retraite minimale avec
la réforme des retraites pour justement
augmenter un peu le niveau de vie des
retraités avec 1300 vous en sortez pas
parce que vous avez deux petits enfants
mais il y a beaucoup de retraités qui
avec 1100 sur sortent encore moins donc
voilà vous êtes très courageuse d'avoir
pris un job à côté ça me fera un peu le
cœur parce que quand on a bossé toute sa
vie qu'on a cotisé toute sa vie la
retraite c'est le moment du repos et ce
repos il est mérité donc sachez que l'un
des objectifs de cette réforme au-delà
du fait d'équilibrer le financement
c'est aussi de faire en sorte que nos
retraités vivent mieux dans notre pays
alors justement cette réforme des
retraites
beaucoup de gens étaient dans la rue
encore aujourd'hui pour s'y opposer
ce qui vous est reproché c'est surtout
de ne pas prendre en compte la
pénibilité de certains certaines
activités certains travaillent alors
aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il est possible parce que
c'est je vous dis peut-être encore une
bêtise parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
des gens qui sont dans des bureaux qui
qui ont voilà qui peuvent travailler
jusqu'à 60 75 76 il y a des choix des
gens qui travaillent jusqu'à 80 des
chefs d'entreprises des des personnes
qui ont des travail des travaux peu
pénibles un travail peu pénible et par
contre d'un autre côté on a des gens qui
travaillent dans le bâtiment qui se sont
réveillés tous les jours à 6h du matin
qui ont mangé leur gamelle à midi pour
prendre une heure de
c'est impossible c'est trop compliqué ce
serait trop non seulement c'est pas
impossible mais en fait on va enfin le
faire vraiment en fait là vous allez
prendre en compte ça parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on va faire plusieurs points en fait
jusqu'ici il y avait ce qu'on appelait
des critères de pénibilité honnêtement
si on avait compris comment ça marchait
c'est qu'on nous l'avait mal expliqué ce
truc qui était absolument
invraisemblable fallait compter le
nombre d'heures on exposait à tel
vibration etc etc personne ne rentrait
vraiment dans les cases on l'avait
supprimé parce que ça ne marchait pas et
là finalement maintenant on va
reconnaître des métiers comme des
métiers à risque de pénibilité et toutes
les personnes qui sont dans ces métiers
on sera capable de les considérer comme
ayant eu un métier pénible plutôt
jusqu'à preuve du contraire c'est à dire
que on simplifie on va matifier la
reconnaissance des critères de
pénibilité on veut y ajouter des
critères donc les vibrations le port de
charge lourdes l'exposition des
températures extrêmes et de travail de
nuit etc on simplifie ces critères de
manière à ce que les gens rentrent plus
facilement dans la catégorie métier
pénible ils pourront partir deux ans à
l'avance
on va pas faire que ça c'est-à-dire
qu'un ouvrier qui a travaillé dans le
BTP par exemple un maçon ou un carreleur
une aide-soignante va pouvoir continuer
de partir plus tôt c'était et donc on
simplifie au contraire ça ce qui va
d'ailleurs nous coûter de l'argent dans
la réforme mais on l'assume justement
ensuite on dit et ça moi j'aime bien
cette logique plutôt de voir quelqu'un à
60 ans qui a les reins hors d'usage les
genoux avec des prothèses etc plutôt que
de dire ah bah allez il faut partir la
retraite parce que là ça peut plus durer
on va faire davantage de prévention et
donc on va mettre une consultation
médicale à 45 ans et si besoin une autre
consultation c'est la personne ne
continuait à bosser à 61 ans pour
pouvoir faire justement un premier bilan
de santé et se dire là vous pouvez pas
continuer
l'autre chose qui est hyper important
dans la réforme et personne n'en parle
pour moi c'est vraiment un truc majeur
c'est qu'on va faire un congé de
reconversion professionnelle imaginez
Cyril vous travaillez on verra le nombre
d'années mais imaginons 10 ou 12 je sais
pas combien d'années encore dans un
métier pénible d'accord c'est là ce soir
c'est pas encore plus pénible que ça
Baba pour vous imaginez vous fassiez ce
métier et bien et vous dites moi j'en ai
marre d'être sympa terminé on va vous
vous allez garder votre salaire pendant
un an alors que vous ne travaillez plus
vous allez partir vers une formation
vous allez choisir pour voir une
reconversion professionnelle vers un
métier non pénible et on va vous payer
cette formation donc un an de salaire
conservé et une formation payée pour
changer de branche je pense que la
plupart des personnes qui sont là ce
soir ne le savez mais c'est pour ça que
je dis faut bien retenir un truc en gros
la réforme elle nous permet d'avoir 18
milliards de plus par an pour financer
les retraites et sur ces 18 milliards il
y en a 6 qu'on va engager en dépense
nouvelle et notamment pour les gens qui
sont en invalidité en situation de
handicap avec de la pénibilité les
reconversions professionnelles il faut
aussi comprendre que moi je l’ai compris
ça je vais dire je veux bien prendre le
je veux bien reconnaître quelque chose
et notamment je sais pas s'il y a des
jeunes qui m'interpelleront sur la
réforme qui est là je crois je sais pas
si les jeunes en particulier ou non mais
aujourd'hui
de passer la parole et puis je reprends
après si vous êtes d'accord non mais ça
m'évite de faire des tunnels et voilà ça
sera plus intéressant
bonsoir Monsieur Baba
alors avant de commencer si possible
j'aimerais rendre hommage à toutes les
personnes qui ont manifesté aujourd'hui
toutes les travailleuses tous les
travailleurs
en chantant à Marseille si c'est
possible je peux vous voulez chanter la
marseillais vous voulez la chanter avec
Stone parce que avec plaisir
chanter le devant le ou alors on passe
direct
de
la contre nous
de la tyrannie
l'étendard sanglantes élevés
les tendances
élevés
entendez-vous
dans les campagnes
mugir c'est féroces soldats
[Musique]
égorgé nos fils et vos compagnes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quad
alors déjà je préfère largement la
Marseillaise à l'international donc
merci pour ça merci et ensuite ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui c'est une vraie
manifestation avec beaucoup de gens je
respecte il y avait beaucoup de gens
dans les rues de France c'était pas un
esprit révolutionnaire qui régnait c'est
un esprit de contestation je fais la
différence entre les deux et après j'ai
un profond respect pour la Marseillaise
vous l'avez très bien chanté merci
bon alors racontez-moi moi ça fait 15
ans que je suis Gauthier donc j'ai 34
ans
donc moi la question que je me pose
comme tous mes confrères grutiers qui
nous regardent peut-être ce soir que je
salue comment est-ce que je vais faire à
64 ans Monsieur Véran pour grimper des
échelles à 30 mètres parce qu'à partir
de 30 mètres ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que la société est obligée d'installer
un ascenseur ce qui est pas toujours le
cas donc à partir de 30 mètres à 64 ans
comment je vais faire pour arriver donc
dans ma cabine et travailler avec
rigueur avec soin
sans trembler avec une vue peut-être qui
va diminuer comment je vais être aussi
efficace et comment est-ce que je vais
faire pour être aussi productif
travailler dans une avec de la sécurité
à 64 ans voilà ça c'est ma question
alors fade vous avez commencé à quel âge
18 ans à 18 ans 18 ans c'est bon et donc
pourquoi vous parlez 64 ans
je vous explique j'explique carrière
longue ça veut dire que quand on a
commencé plus tôt on part plutôt
d'accord et en l'occurrence vous avez
commencé à 18 ans 18 ans pile poil ou un
petit peu avant
que vous allez partir à la retraite en
fait à 62 ans alors qu'aujourd'hui vous
devriez partir à la retraite à
62 ans et voilà donc pour vous 250 juin
excusez-moi
excusez-moi même à 62 ans vous auriez pu
partir à 61 ou 62 ans en fonction de
comment vous avez d'abord c'est pas 64
ans donc ça je vais vous dire que la
réforme qu'on est en train d'adopter
elle ne change pas fondamentalement les
choses pour vous puisque normalement ce
sera quasiment kif par rapport à ce que
vous auriez c'est ce qu'on appelle les
carrières langues d'accord et donc
j'insiste là-dessus tout le monde ne
part pas à 64 ans en réalité il y a près
d'un Français sur deux qui partira avant
64 ans ce qu'on commençait tôt ceux qui
ont des invalidités ce qu'on a
pénibilité etc après je connais pas le
métier de grutier et je dois vous dire
que j'ai un vertige au-dessus d'un
tabouret donc je montrais jamais je vous
invite si vous êtes si vous êtes vol je
vous invite à monter avec moi j'ai fait
beaucoup de trucs comme députés ou comme
bedies parce que j'aime bien vivre ce
que vivent les gens au quotidien mais
alors la grue la grue faudra vraiment
faire boire beaucoup avant que je monte
et du coup je serai ce serait pas
sécurisé pour moi j'ai un trop gros donc
je je respecte infiniment ce que vous
faites bon merci j'imagine que dans une
grue ça vibre pas mal et que vous êtes
exposé à des températures de mettre
assez extrêmes c'est ça donc je serai
pas complètement étonné si vous voulez
que dans les accords de branche
professionnels on reconnaisse aussi des
critères de pénibilité donc tout ça fait
qu'à mon avis vous allez partir mais
plutôt avant ce que vous imaginez encore
à la retraite ok alors ensuite fade vous
êtes énergique je devine un profil
plutôt porté sur la solidarité et vous
êtes peut-être même quelqu'un d'assez
curieux c'est trop peut-être je suis pas
je suis pas le nouveau mentaliste
mais je vois en discutant du coup est-ce
que vous vous envisagez ça peut être
votre choix est-ce que vous envisagez de
faire le même métier tout au long de
votre vie ou pas non non j'ai pas
complètement tort dans ce que vous voyez
en voyant des collègues assez âgés
travailler dans la grue alors pas
forcément dans la grue je parle aussi
des des coffeurs
je sais pas j'aimerais bien merci
complètement différent dans le cinéma
ou dans la chanson manifestation
bon donc ça veut dire que vous êtes
comme beaucoup de beaucoup de gens on
est de la même génération peut-être mais
à peu près je suis en 88 vous êtes né en
88 génération 34 ans moi je suis né en
88 presque
on fait partie d'une génération en fait
qui pourrait être porte parole du
porte-parole pourquoi pas ou voir
porte-voix parce que vous sentez bien on
fait partie d'une génération en fait qui
a envie de bouger on a des fourmis dans
les pattes c'est-à-dire que quand on
s'engage dans un métier on s'engage pas
aujourd'hui pour 40 ans
si je peux me permettre c'est juste
terminer mon truc ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui on envisage plutôt une
carrière professionnelle comme des
successions de carrière avec des métiers
qui peuvent être très très différents et
il y a cette envie de bouger cette envie
de se dire qu'on va pas rester toute
notre vie figée dans la même entreprise
donc ça aussi on a des trucs vous
regarderez dans la réforme qui sont
faits pour vous pour vous accompagner ce
que j'aimerais vous proposer
vous et à l'ensemble du gouvernement
c'est d'intégrer une entreprise un
métier du pénible une fois dans le mois
un jour ou une semaine je sais pas
paroles incognito non non pas ça mais
pour qu'ils se rende compte en fait de
la pénibilité de chacun des métiers et
qu'il vote des lois en fonction de cette
pénalité vous regardez regardez le texte
emploi du temps chargé vous avez le
droit vous avez regardez juste un
exemple aujourd'hui pour avoir une
reconnaissance de pénibilité quand on
fait des nuits c'est 120 nuits par an là
on le passe à 100 nuits pareil on réduit
le nombre de 3 8 de rotation en 3/8
qu'il faut faire donc on est plutôt on
va plutôt vers le mieux je dis pas que
c'est top je dis pas que c'est top et
moi je préférais que les gens passent
pas un métier pénible pendant des années
si vous me challengez sur la pénibilité
des boulots j'en ai exercé un chef après
je me fais railler parce que quand on
est ministre on a pas le droit d'en
avoir un peu bavé quand on était plus
jeune mais je me dis pas ça pour m'en
plaindre je dis ça parce que oui par une
fierté mais parce que il se trouve que
j'étais aide-soignant en EHPAD de nuit
et donc j'ai touché du doigt ce que
c'est qu'un métier compliqué très mal
payé par reconnu socialement et vous
faites la nuit vous dormez sur le
parking avant d'aller rentrer chez vous
parce que sinon vous avez peur d'avoir
un accident donc je on peut on peut en
discuter ce que je veux vous dire c'est
que ce texte là il n'est pas en train
d'aggraver votre situation il est plutôt
en train de l'améliorer regardez-le si
vous voulez votre situation personnelle
mais la mienne seulement mais on a vu
Josiane tout à l'heure on regarde la
vôtre en fait vous savez l'esprit ouvert
c'est être capable moi je comprends
quelqu'un me dise moi le concept de
travail depuis longtemps j'en veux pas
pas de problème on n'est pas d'accord on
explique pourquoi on fait ce choix on
l'assume nous et ensuite on le porte au
Parlement qui est libre de voter ou non
le texte etc c'est comme ça chaque
réforme des retraites par contre je vous
dis juste regardez par ailleurs ce qu'on
fait pour les personnes dans votre
situation ou dans celle de Josiane pour
essayer d'améliorer en fait le quotidien
et la vie professionnelle des gens et
vous verrez si vous regardez avec
l'esprit un peu plus ouvert que ce qu'on
dit parfois de cette réforme qu'on veut
aussi de temps en temps austraciser avec
des exagérations ça peut être surpris
merci Fred merci merci à vous merci
merci d'avoir donné la parole juste un
petit mot monsieur le mini
lorsque vous m'avez dit là depuis le
début sur cette réforme de retraite
aussi j'ai l'impression que pas mal de
personnes ici comme moi et d'autres
personnes ne connaissent pas bien le
projet de loi est-ce que vous n'allez
pas l'envoyer à tous les Français pour
qu'ils puissent lire vraiment le projet
pour voir vraiment comment on peut faire
pour le retrouver vraiment et pour se
dire voilà quel est le protéger de loi
pour il y a plein de choses dont vous
avez parlé je suis sûr que 90% des
Français n'étaient pas au courant alors
le projet de loi Cyril il est disponible
sur Internet aujourd'hui ensuite il va
être amendé travailler enrichi par les
parlementaires donc il sera un peu
transformé sans doute amélioré après la
lecture au Parlement et ensuite il est
français s'interrogent sur leur propre
situation il y a un simulateur en ligne
rien simulateur en ligne il existe
depuis deux semaines maintenant vous
vous rentrez vos ce que vous avez fait
quand vous l'avez fait et vous regardez
après on assume complètement le fait de
demander aux Français de travailler un
peu plus longtemps on fait pas par
plaisir on le fait par nécessité est-ce
que son équilibré le système mais on
fait plein d'aménagement 63 ans est-ce
que ça aurait changé quelque chose parce
que j'ai discuté avec
développement du gouvernement qui m'a
dit s'ils avaient fait 63 ans ça aurait
été pareil 63 ans en fait on équilibre
pas le système vraiment 63 ans on y
revient dans 5 ans moi je veux bien
qu'on fasse ça tous les 5 ans d'autres
ont fait avant nous mais on équilibre
pas le système et après il faut savoir
que l'âge moyen de départ la retraite ça
va être de combien il est aujourd'hui
pour les Français à quel âge il part 38
non là je moyens là en réalité à quel
âge les Français partent à la retraite
63,3 ans
donc 64 ans en fait non mais je crois
que 68 moi je crois que je sais qu'il y
en a qui travaillent jusqu'à alors ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle il y a 67 ans
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'annulation
l'âge d'annulation de la déco c'est à
dire que vous n'êtes pas jamais obligé
d'aller au-dessus de 67 ans vous perdez
jamais en retraite mais 63,3 ans c'est
l'âge moyen de départ parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens en fait qui vont
travailler après l'âge légal parce
qu'ils veulent améliorer leur retraite
si vous travaillez un peu plus longtemps
que le nombre d'années de cotisations
nécessaires vous améliorez votre pensée
le problème et donc pour eux ça va ça va
pas changer le grand chose mais le
problème c'est que c'est vraiment au cas
par cas c'est à dire qu'il faudrait
créer limite des catégories voilà avec
les différents métiers pour voir
la semaine dernière je suis allé voir
des à l'école Ferrandi qui était une
école de cuisine à Paris j'ai vu une
trentaine de jeunes ils ont tous démarré
ils sont apprentis ils ont tous démarré
à 15 ans et 9 mois ou 15 ans et 8 mois
donc avant avancé 16 ans et j'aurais
posé la question alors il en avait
honnêtement rien à faire de l'âge de
départ là la retraite d'ailleurs quand
vous posez la question à des jeunes le
plus souvent ils vous disent moi j'en
aurai pas ce truc là sera tombé et
justement on se bat pour que les
petits-enfants de Josiane demain qui
cotisent qui cotiseront bientôt par leur
travail pour la retraite de ceux qui
sont retraités comme Josiane puisse
avoir le même système solidaire que
celui dont elle dispose aujourd'hui et
quand j'en pose la question à quel âge
vous partez ils m'ont dit 65 ans alors
ça veut dire que déjà le fait que c'est
plus 65 mais 64 c'est pas passé complet
puis surtout j'aurais dit que vous avez
démarré en fait avant 16 ans vous allez
partir à 58 ans 58 ans donc plutôt
qu'avant la réforme